muy bien estamos en la pagina 471 en la
sección 6 y voy a hacer el primer
ejercicio en más gente el primer
ejercicio de esta sección que dice si
tengo 3 + rombo + rombo esto entre 2 es
lo mismo que 7 enteros un medio lo que
me preguntan es cuánto vale rombo y tal
vez para no complicarnos la vida podemos
decir que el rombo es x vamos a ponerlo
aquí para hacernos la vida más fácil y
verlo de una manera que ya sabemos el
rumbo va a ser igual a x entonces me va
a quedar 3 + x entre 2 esto tiene que
ser igual a 7 enteros un medio pero 7
enteros un medio es lo mismo que 2 por
714 más 1 1515
muy bien pase esta fracción mixta a una
fracción impropia y ahora se multiplicó
a ambos lados por 2
voy a multiplicar esta parte por 2 y
esta parte por 2 entonces este 2 y este
2 se van este 2 y este 2 se van y me
queda que 3 más
x esto es igual a 15 y restando 3 de
ambos lados de la ecuación me va a
quedar que x es igual a 12 y ya está
x o más bien el rombo el rombo que era
lo que yo quería es igual a 12 y este es
el inciso de hacer que ya está nuestro
primer problema y creo que todavía nos
cabe aquí el segundo problema así que
vamos a ver el problema número 2 que por
cierto tiene una figura muy parecida a
ésta
tengo una recta por aquí
tengo otra vez está por aquí
bien y después tengo una recta que cruza
por acá y tengo un montón de números
tengo aquí el 12
aquí el 3 de aquí el 4
si te das cuenta todos estos números son
ángulos aquí tengo el 5 y el 6
aquí el 7 y aquí el 8 y me dicen que
esta recta está que por ti tiene una
flecha por aquí se llama la recta l y
esta recta esta recta que también tiene
una flecha por acá se llama la recta m y
me dicen si la figura siguiente la recta
l y la recta m son paralelas entonces la
suma del ángulo 2 y el ángulo 4 es
equivalente a la suma de qué otro par de
ángulos
es decir la suma de este ángulo más este
ángulo yo quiero ver que esto sea igual
a la suma de otro par de ángulos que por
cierto nosotros sabemos que este ángulo
y este ángulo son iguales porque son
ángulos opuestos y si nosotros
recordamos nuestras clases de geometría
de una manera muy sencilla podemos saber
que como esta y estas son rectas
paralelas
entonces el ángulo correspondiente a
este en esta recta sería el ángulo 6 y
bueno este ángulo correspondiente a éste
tiene la misma medida y además tiene la
misma medida que el ángulo 4 y el ángulo
4 tiene como ángulo correspondiente este
ángulo el ángulo 8 y entonces la suma
del ángulo 2 y el ángulo 4 es
exactamente lo mismo que la suma del
ángulo 6 y el ángulo 8 porque son
ángulos correspondientes porque estas
dos rectas son paralelas entonces así de
fácil estaba este problema que por
cierto también
el inciso de así que bueno y aquí tengo
la respuesta del problema 2 vamos a
resolver el problema 3 déjenme borrar
esta pantalla y poner aquí el problema
número 3 que tiene una tabla entonces
déjame copiar aquí la tabla porque creo
que la vamos a utilizar así que déjenme
utilizar esta herramienta para hacer la
tabla tenemos una tabla muy parecida a
ésta es algo así y después tengo
23 columnas así que voy a ponerlas esta
es una columna esta es otra columna y
después tengo tres filas una por aquí
algo así y otra fila por acá tengo otra
fila por acá o no espera espera espera
de hecho debe ser un poco más arriba es
una fila por acá perfecto y después
tengo aquí algunos numeritos en primer
lugar aquí dice hombres hombres acá
abajo dice mujeres
mujeres
y hasta acá abajo dice total total
y aquí arriba dice hombres
aquí se empleados
pleados
aquí dice desempleados desempleados y
aquí total también total y tengo este
dato me dan que los hombres empleados
son 27.000 27.000 también me dicen que
el total de empleados son 48.000 tengo
48 mil personas empleadas muy bien y por
otra parte tengo este total que es 21
mil 521 mil 500 es decir tengo un total
de 21 mil quinientas mujeres y tengo un
total de los totales de 50 mil
quinientos cincuenta mil quinientos muy
bien ahora el problema me dice lo
siguiente en esta tabla está el personal
que hay en la ciudad princeton tanto
empleados como desempleados sin embargo
a la tablet le falta información cuánto
personal femenino está desempleado es
decir esencialmente lo que queremos
saber es
mujeres desempleadas que hay en la
ciudad princeton
queremos saber esta parte de la tabla y
como la vamos a obtener
bueno se me ocurre utilizar esta
información que tenemos por ejemplo aquí
dice que tenemos 48 mil personas
empleadas de los cuales 27 mil son
hombres entonces cuántas mujeres debe de
haber pues debe de haber la diferencia
entre estos 248 mil menos 27.000 es
21.000 hay 21 mil mujeres empleadas muy
bien y si ahora yo lo que quiero saber
es o mira podemos sacar las mujeres
desempleadas utilizando este otro dato
en total de mujeres empleadas y
desempleadas hay 21 mil 500 hay 21 mil
500 mujeres en la ciudad princeton pero
21 mil son empleadas por lo tanto
cuántas mujeres desempleadas
debe de haber pues es la diferencia de
estos dos que es 500 la diferencia de
estos dos es 500 y ya está si yo lo que
quiero saber es cuánto personal femenino
está desempleado
bueno pues son 500 mujeres las que están
desempleadas
es el inciso a muy bien
déjenme cambiar el color a otro color
que no sea tan nauseabundo y voy a hacer
el problema número 4 el problema número
4 y espero que me quepa aquí un grupo de
estudiantes va a lavar carros para
obtener dinero el total de dinero
en pesos obtenido por la barca autos
está dado por la siguiente función y la
función es adecam esta función es
importante es igual a 4 k menos 30 menos
30 la cantidad de dinero obtenida por la
marca autos es igual a 4 k menos 30 si
el grupo de estudiantes lavo 15
automóviles cuál es la cantidad de
dinero que juntaron a esto está muy
fácil no lo puedo creer porque
esencialmente lo que te dicen es que
lavaron 15 automóviles es decir que acá
vale 15 la cantidad de automóviles que
lavaron fue 15 y bueno sí sé que acá
vale 15 pues
que enchufarlo aquí sustituir el valor
de acá aquí para saber cuánto ganaron es
decir que hay de 15 de 15 autos que
lavaron esto es igual a 4 por 15
-30 así de fácil y de sencillo y habrá
que calcular cuánto es esto esto es lo
mismo que 4 por 15 es lo mismo que 30
por 2 es 60 60 menos 30 esto es 30
ganaron 30 pesos y no lo puedo creer que
esté tan fácil estos problemas bueno
recuerda que al principio de cada una de
las pruebas y de cada una de las
secciones están los ejercicios más
fáciles y después se ponen unos
ejercicios bastante interesantes así que
bueno déjame cambiar esta pantalla y
vamos a hacer un nuevo problema voy a
trabajar con el problema número 5 y este
problema me dice lo siguiente los huevos
en una cierta canasta son de color
blanco o de color arena si la razón
entre los huevos de color blanco con
respecto a los huevos de color arena es
de dos tercios creo que eso es
importante a los huevos de color blanco
están a una relación 2 de 3 huevos de
color arena
vamos a ponerlo así si yo tengo la razón
entonces los huevos de color blanco
y de hecho déjenme ponerlo con color
blanco para que veas que son huevos de
color blanco blancos los blancos entre
los color arena déjame poner un color
arena este es parecido al color arena no
es tanto pero bueno entre los color
arena esto es igual a dos tercios muy
bien y dice cuál de los siguientes
incisos no puede ser una cantidad
correcta de huevos en la canasta
cuál de los siguientes insisto no puede
ser una cantidad correcta de huevos en
la canasta cómo puedo responder eso
bueno primero date cuenta de algo si de
aquí despejó a los blancos oa los huevos
de color arena que me va a quedar a ver
vamos a ponerlo los huevos blancos es lo
mismo que y voy a pasar los huevos de
color arena multiplicando para acá que
dos tercios han déjame cambiar color
arena que dos tercios los huevos de
color arena eso por una parte pero por
otra parte yo sé que los huevos de la
canasta los huevos de la canasta queda
son pues son todos los blancos más todos
los huevos color arena y si de aquí
sustituyó está en esta otra que tengo
aquí sí aquí enchufo este valor que
estoy obteniendo y bueno esto para saber
cuál es la cantidad de huevos que
necesito en la canasta que me va a
quedar me va a quedar dos tercios de los
huevos de arena
estos son los huevos blancos esto es lo
mismo que ven
más los huevos de arena que por cierto
los huevos color arena y aquí es lo
mismo que tres tercios uno es lo mismo
que tres tercios y esto me queda igual a
cinco tercios de los huevos de arena es
decir que me tiene que quedar una
cantidad que yo la pueda ver o
representar de esta manera por ejemplo
el inciso a haber déjame ponerlo aquí el
inciso am me dice que la cantidad de
huevos es igual a 10 es decir que cinco
tercios de los huevos de arena debe de
ser 10 y vamos a ver si esto es posible
si yo paso este 5 tercios del otro lado
o dicho de otra manera multiplicó por el
inverso multiplicativo me va a quedar
que aquí tengo que multiplicar por tres
quintos aquí tengo que multiplicar por
tres quintos y entonces esto se van y me
queda que am es igual a 10
por 3 entre 5 estos dos se pueden
cancelar y me queda aquí 2 y entonces 2
x 3 es 6 por lo tanto la opción a es una
opción correcta o dicho de otra manera
lo podremos visualizar en la siguiente
forma la cantidad total de huevos en la
canasta tienen que ser los blancos más
los de arena que es 5 tercios es decir
la cantidad total tiene que ser igual a
5 tercios a 5 tercios de los huevos de
arena de color de arena o dicho de otra
manera si multiplicó por tres quintos la
cantidad de huevos de color arena tiene
que ser igual a 3 sobre 5 la cantidad
total de huevos y yo lo que quiero es
encontrar un número que no sea divisible
entre 5 porque recuerda que la cantidad
total de huevos tiene que ser un número
de hecho entero positivo no puede ser
una fracción no podemos tener dos
tercios de huevo por lo tanto tiene que
ser un entero positivo 1
y utilizando esta información de todas
las opciones que me dan la única que no
es divisible entre 5 es el inciso b el
inciso b es la que no es divisible entre
5 que es justo lo que queríamos cuál de
los siguientes incisos no puede ser una
cantidad correcta de huevos en esta
canasta así que ya está tengo aquí el
inciso b y estoy justo en el tiempo así
que los dejo por ahora y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo